all right guys
bang bang got an awesome episode today
with
josh thank you so much for joining us
sir thanks for having me on
absolutely you've got an amazing
background in terms of you've worked at
some of the most innovative companies in
the world and now you've started
a company that's really pioneering kind
of this bio wearable space
before we get into what you're doing
today i want to go back tell us a little
bit about your background
what you did at spacex and at hyperloop
and then we'll talk a little about those
companies
definitely um i grew up in northern
virginia
a little bit south of dc had big
property i was always into machines
most particularly cars motorcycles dirt
bikes always building stuff
and i decided to go to school for
mechanical engineering
and kind of spent some time on
thermodynamics and heat transfer and not
really knowing what i wanted to do other
than work on machines and vehicles and
so ultimately after school spent a brief
stint
selling used cars and then uh got the
call i was waiting for and went and
worked at spacex for about six years
and uh that that was for sure
one of the highlights of my life and uh
you know during during my time there i
think i
completely changed as a human being uh
like end to end just completely
transformed
the way i think about the world uh where
i see myself on the hierarchy of
intelligence
way closer to the bottom than i had
previously thought um
but it was it was an unbelievable
experience and i met some of the best
people um
in my life you know who are who will be
close to me to the
forever i hope and uh and generally
learned you know i i learned
essentially how to solve problems from
first principles
and you know using using that
foundational like what is the simplest
solution that gets us to an iterative
step
forward right that that sort of mindset
is is just rampant in
uh in spacex and i think in elon
companies generally
sort of an occam's razor type approach
where you just like
go for the simplest solution typically
and uh and
also attract really exceptional people
with a big
a big mission so um that was an
unbelievable experience i i
eventually worked on the uh astronaut
life support program so spacex was
previously
you know they were a satellite launch
provider initially and then
uh the big transition came when
it became clear that that part of the
business was working and now it was time
to try and take humans into space and
that's like a fundamental rewrite of the
organization you know
now you have human lives at stake and uh
it's no longer an empty shell it's like
gotta keep keem alive in there so i was
one of the earliest employees on the
life support program at spacex and was
able to
uh work on that in partnership with nasa
all the way through to the critical
design review phase
uh got that across the finish line and
then moved over to hyperloop and spent
about a year kind of specking out the
earliest full-scale system
for hyperloop demonstration and for
people who aren't familiar with that
that system is essentially a maglev
train so a magnetically levitating
high-speed train inside of a tube and
you evacuate all the air out of the tube
so there's no aerodynamic resistance
and so now with very limited power draw
you can
maintain really high speeds so much
higher than a maglev train in open air
can do
so we we built a full scale concept out
in
las vegas and i was i was able to work
on that design some life support stuff
and then um
ultimately got obsessed with human
performance and and metabolism and
started levels so that's where we are
now
so let's talk a little bit about this
idea of like first principles thinking
and almost the simplistic solution
obviously
elon's fingerprints are kind of all over
both of the companies that you just
described
but walk through like are there specific
examples where you saw
this in practice or was it something
that maybe
there was an experience or some kind of
training that really got you from what
i'll call
a civilian uh to now kind of be fully
indoctrinated into
this type of thinking and and uh and
really kind of problem solving
yeah i think it so it's a pervasive
culture of simplicity
and um the the easiest way to describe
this is like
as a really green engineer going into
one of my first meetings at the company
my expectation was that i was going to
have to take notes
and research a lot of what i heard in
that meeting afterwards
to understand what was happening because
i did not anticipate that i would be
able to
pick up on the language of advanced
engineering
and the result was actually that it was
a a
essentially a first 101 level
conversation
about designing a product that could be
very complicated if you wanted it to be
but because spacex eliminates acronyms
and jargon
it's not allowed no one is allowed to
use industry speak
i as a you know fresh out of school
engineer understood everything that was
being talked about and it was being
spoken about in
sort of like an explain like i'm five
approach and it's very
it's like it sounds a little weird
initially when you hear conversations at
spacex
because they're sort of like well what
if we make it bigger uh what if we make
it like
what if we make it out of titanium
instead of aluminum that'll be lighter
and then we can add more you know the
volume will be
you know improved and and so there's
sort of like all these conversations
that are just
maintaining very low level terminology
so that if anyone catches on
and the goal here is that whoever is in
the meeting privy to the conversation no
matter what their background
or what their responsibility set is they
can understand and potentially
contribute to problem solving and if you
create artificial barriers of complexity
just your language creates barriers um
you know if i had had to take
notes in that meeting and go look things
up that means i couldn't contribute in
the meeting and i may never get back to
those
that same group of people in that same
context at that point in the project to
offer my
insight and just because i didn't have
insight at that moment doesn't mean that
i didn't in the future and
um many many times mid-stream in
conversation
people would just hear an idea and say
why don't you try this
um and and the company you know spacex
is a very build test iterate
company so it's it's you if you are
waiting to build a complex version of a
potential solution
before you test it where it might fail
and you have to start over again
you're you're going to inevitably spend
more money and more time doing so
so if there's a version of a concept and
one example is
um the so the
the spacecraft the the crew dragon
spacecraft
when it when it mates to the
international space station it uses this
uh this really complicated system uh
called a docking adapter
and it sort of like floats and adapts to
the iss both vehicles are moving at
different rates and then different
angles and they connect and like grab
onto each other
and originally we were supposed to have
to buy this system off an existing
aerospace provider and it was going to
be
on the order of you know close to 50
million dollars something like that
and instead a team of engineers said
there's a simpler way to do this and
they built
using mcmaster car parts which is like a
it's an e-commerce hardware store online
and snowmobile springs they built what
we called the mcdocker which was
uh i think it was on the order like 20
000 worth of parts that did everything
that the 50 million dollar component
would have done
and they demonstrated it live and that
was the build test iterate approach that
allowed
like that we were constantly using it at
spacex it was like i think i can do this
with parts that are laying in my garage
so i'm going to and then i'm going to
record a video of it and share it with
the team
and in in traditional aerospace that
doesn't really happen you know you don't
you don't have that license to
kind of hack things together if
necessary um
and you know the it goes all the way to
the top so like i remember
when the falcon 9 version 1.1 rocket
first flew
it it tried to re-light its engine so so
rockets traditionally burn up in
you know on re-entry so they put their
satellite in space and then
fall back into the atmosphere and burn
up well
um spacex was trying to land them and
recover them and re-fly them
and when that first falcon 9 flew that
was able to re-light its engine
and it wasn't able to land because it
didn't have any weight to do so but it
re-light
its engine and slowed down elon
basically went on stage
afterwards and said so we're now gonna
now that that rocket
did what it was supposed to do like
we're just gonna put legs on it
and land it because that way it'll be
able to land and
if you if you want to land like you need
to have legs to land on and it was like
the mo
it was like a child explaining something
but that is the that's the
example i want to drive home is just
that the simplicity of the language
pervades the end solution it ended up
that we just put legs on
falcon 9 and it landed you know what i
mean and often times you can get caught
up in thinking about
crazy complexity when at the end of the
day if you just describe it in a
simplest form
that might be what you can do how much
of the language
ends up determining the simplicity of
the design
versus the simplicity of the design
determines the language like is there a
causation there or they both go hand in
hand
i really think it goes hand in hand i
mean you um
by by creating
i think by creating a space where you
can
speak in very simple terms and describe
very simple concepts without
embarrassing yourself you
you actually create sort of a
competition where
i mean some of the conversations as i
mentioned are kind of bizarre where
engineers are literally talking
in absurdly simplistic terms about
very ultimately complex complex complex
concepts
and uh i so i think it's bi-directional
i think
by having a mental model that is like
driven by simple language
you are keeping yourself at the root of
the problem
you're not getting caught up in uh you
know as you learn more about a space and
you get deeper into an industry you pick
up on jargon and
descriptors that are uh much more
abstract and
and by default like if they are abstract
descriptors that you need to be deep in
the industry to understand
they aren't the core of the of the
concept like if you look at the
wikipedia description of a
system that's the that's like the first
principles
associated with it you know it it moves
people from point a to point b
you know that's kind of like what you're
solving and anything beyond that is
is no longer your first principle
solution like if you're not solving
moving someone from point a to point b
you're on some sort of extraneous part
of the problem
so by keeping the language focused there
and uh
and then simultaneously i think
rewarding simple scrappy solutions in
terms of like what you're actually
building
you can create a culture that is like
competing for simplicity and and i think
that actually ultimately means elegance
because um i i feel allergic to
complexity generally you know the deeper
we have to go the more parts that you
have to bolt on to put things together
there's just more failure modes there's
more people that have to be in the loop
it uh it generally creates bloat and and
so
fewer simpler more elegant in my mind
yeah the whole idea of like simplicity
equals beauty i think is very very true
and it's cool to see it kind of
implemented in a business and especially
in a highly technical
and what many people think is a highly
complex
uh type of you know hardware type
business
let's talk a little bit about levels uh
it's an amazing product
um but before we talk about the product
what exactly is the problem that you're
going after you're talking a lot about
kind of
um this metabolic fitness or kind of
metabolic awareness and pursuit of
metabolic fitness
talk about like where is the impetus for
this idea what was the problem how did
you come across it and why did it kind
of catch your eye and you're so
passionate about it
yeah so essentially
levels solves the question of what
should i eat and why
and you know we have wearables that tell
us a lot about
what's happening you know with our step
count and with our heart rate and such
a lot of exercise and sleep tracking but
we don't have anything to answer a
fundamental question which is
uh where is my energy coming from and uh
how well
is my body functioning at producing that
energy and so this is the
the concept of metabolism essentially
every tissue every cell in the body
requires energy to function and where it
gets that energy is from our food and
environment so the
the calories we consume the sunlight
that we absorb
and uh this is this concept of
metabolism is very abstract for society
but in fact it is
you know metabolic fitness which is
the efficiency with which we're
producing energy for our brains and our
muscles and the rest of the tissues in
our bodies
fundamentally underlies physical fitness
and mental fitness
so we spend a lot of time trying to
perform better in the gym and perform
better at work
um but at the end of the day we ne we
never think about
the foundation for both of those which
is how well are we producing the energy
for our brains and bodies
and and so um that's that's what levels
is seeking to do is to optimize
metabolic fitness by using real-time
data
in as essentially a as closed-loop a
feedback style as possible meaning when
you take an action
you receive feedback on how well that
performed for you or how well you did
uh your you know the reaction you
experienced how uh how positive or
negative that was
within as near zero time as possible
right so
closing that gap to the maximum degree
that we can
so uh the concepts that you throughout
their metabolic awareness month about
fitness you know
metabolic fitness is the goal we all
want to incrementally improve day after
day
and um as with anything you know focus
effort and repetition are necessary to
improve
uh physical fitness mental fitness and
metabolic fitness
so the decisions we're making they
compound over time
into a positive or negative result and
if we don't have feedback on whether
we're heading into positive or negative
direction
we have no way of achieving metabolic
fitness because we don't know which
direction we're heading
and so metabolic awareness is that
feedback it's
the moment where your body has a closed
loop of
a data stream essentially to your brain
telling you
positively or negatively how well you're
doing
and so the level system essentially we
take in feedback
um well we take in data from
what we call biowearables so these are
devices which are
measuring a molecule in the body this is
fundamentally different from a
traditional wearable which is
measuring sort of a superficial marker
so pulse which you can measure with your
finger or step count which you can
kind of just count um in this case it's
a molecule that would otherwise not be
measurable without this device
and we we take that data in context with
your lifestyle choices so the nutrition
decisions you're making
your stress level your sleep quality and
uh
and your exercise and we pull out
insights to help you understand
specifically how well your body is
functioning
and where your areas for opportunity for
improvement are
got it and so as you're doing this um
maybe let's talk about
uh kind of the traditional wearable
market so you talked about pulse you
talked about step count
uh there's a whole bunch of them you
know everything from a whoop band to an
apple watch
uh all the way on down and really what
those seem to be focused on
is what i'll call output right in terms
of it's the physical body doing an
activity um and what is the impact of
doing that activity so you can get
everything from very simple just how
many steps did you walk today to
hey you walked a lot of steps which
meant you burnt a lot of calories and
then you slept well tonight and that
is all connected and we'll tell you that
and so that's very very valuable for
people
but what you're really focused on is the
input of what's going
in the body so how do you actually
measure
what's going in the body like what does
the the product look like today
and what is it doing when somebody puts
it on
so it's a complicated problem ultimately
uh metabolism is
it's describing the chemical reactions
going on
in your body you know the human body is
essentially a large chemistry set with a
lot of chemicals being released in
response to other chemicals
and so it's it's not like uh you know a
very clean machine where gears are
connected and you turn the crank and
energy comes out it's actually you're
you're pouring chemicals into your body
all the time
and and then hormones have to be
released to
essentially to uh allocate where those
chemicals those resources end up and
that might be weight gain that might be
to the brain for
for cognitive functioning that might be
to the muscles for exercise
all of that is dictated by hormones and
complex processes and signaling
by uh by other markers chemical markers
so in in this country we have
an extremely concerning
yet largely unspoken about epidemic
of metabolic dysfunction where you know
the university of north carolina
released a study in 2018 showing that 88
of adults in the united states are
metabolically unhealthy
and the cdc is constantly releasing
scarier and scarier updates where
younger and younger people are getting
uh you know type 2 diabetes
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
all of these concerning side effects of
very poor diet and chronic lifestyle
decisions
and so at a point where 90 million
americans have pre-diabetes
70 of whom will become type 2 diabetic
if they don't do something about it and
yet we have no feedback system
to tell us whether what we're doing is
working in our favor
we ultimately are are heading in the
wrong direction and flying blind when
doing so
so uh the question of how to measure
input versus output is a tricky one you
know ultimately we need
behavior change we need to make better
choices but
you know it's much easier to focus on
the outputs than it is on the inputs
it's very tricky to get like really good
data on what's going into the body
so the way that levels attacks this is
by highlighting for the
for the user you know for that member
who's using the levels
product we highlight for them the way
their body reacted
to a specific input right so you eat a
meal
let's say you have a pizza well you tap
that into the levels
uh interface take a picture and then
let's say you sit on the couch
levels monitors using the continuous
glucose information coming from the bio
wearable
we monitor the way your body responded
to that pizza
and we then surface that to you as a
score so just a simple score out of 10
and that's the output
but you are you see the input it was a
pizza and i sat on the couch and the
output was of a negative response my
body experienced
a prolonged blood sugar elevation
followed by a hypoglycemic reactive
crash when
i was flooded with insulin insulin
stores glucose as fat so
i gained body fat as a function of this
and and then
we encourage you to try something
different to compare that input to to a
different set of inputs
and so this time we maybe recommend have
that same pizza but this time
take a walk around the block so take 20
25 minutes
and immediately after finishing that
pizza instead of sitting down go walk
around
and now you see a completely different
output which is that
for many of us our are the muscles in
our posterior chain that are powering
that walk
can absorb glucose without insulin that
fat gain hormone
as long as they're being contracted as
long as you're exercising them
and so now you know you eat that same
pizza you go for a walk and your body
experiences a totally different blood
sugar response and
correspondingly a totally different
hormone response and then we surface
those two
sets of inputs and outputs for you to
compare
so we can show you like just a simple
stroll after every meal
can completely transform the way your
body is processing those meals
and the load you're putting on your
hormonal system how your body is forced
to respond and allocate those resources
so
that's where we focus is at the end of
the day we want to make sure that the
person who needs to make better choices
is being presented with all the
information and we only want to pull in
as much
input as necessary to highlight a
necessity in an
essentially so we don't make you tap in
calories or
macronutrient count or kind of anything
that most nutrition apps
make you make you focus on we instead
just focus on
closing that loop between the input and
the ultimate output
all right so let's go back to the way
that you're measuring this
is it's a patch that essentially goes
on the back of an arm and what exactly
is happening with that patch
yeah so um this technology is called a
continuous glucose monitor
and it was developed over the past few
decades in the lab and then ultimately
was moved into
the therapeutic space for people with
diabetes
and essentially what it's doing is when
you have diabetes the the insulin
glucose
feedback loop is broken down so
basically when
when you eat carbohydrates glucose gets
into the blood that's a it's a form of
sugar it's in your bloodstream
uh the hormone insulin has to be
released by your pancreas
to get that glucose out of your blood
and if it doesn't it can start to cause
serious tissue damage
so for people with diabetes they they
really have to have a full-time
high-resolution awareness of their blood
sugar levels
historically they've had to prick their
finger every single time they need a
blood sugar measurement
and that just gives you one point in
time it says you're you know you're at
106.
and you have no idea if you're going up
or you're going down or you know where
you were two hours ago
so this amazing technology which is a
cgm which is
essentially a tiny little patch it's
about the size of two quarters
and there's this little flexible
filament on the underside of it
and that filament is very hair like
essentially it sits in the skin and it
actually interacts directly with
glucose molecules and so this this
breakthrough
over the past roughly 10 years has
allowed people to go
from pricking their finger you know
dozens of times a day to having a
continuous
full-time data stream right to their
phone and that is telling you glucose in
say five minute increments without
having to prick your finger without any
mass or inconvenience
and um and so that that's the
development process for the tech it's
typically a wired
wireless data transfer from this little
patch that you wear
full time for about two weeks directly
to the phone
and you know we're now getting to a
point where again the convenience factor
the price point and the usability the
usefulness of this information
has made it such that we can start to
expand it to
areas outside of therapy right so it's
no longer just necessary that you have
diabetes that you're managing but in
fact we can start to focus on
optimization
so whether or not you have diabetes no
matter where you are in the metabolic
health spectrum
we can be making better choices you know
if we have better insight
i'm sitting down to eat lunch what am i
going to eat and why well
we can now ground that in objective data
and so that that's
the currently the application we're
using cgm for and that platform
i expect will will include many more
analytes in the in the coming years
yeah and what's so interesting to me
about this is the obvious thing would be
hey you had this you know kind of
persistent flat
uh glucose level you ate a bunch of
candy and now all of a sudden it's
spiked
uh you shouldn't do that anymore right
so kind of a very binary eat this don't
eat that
but you highlighted an example of it's
not just
a single perspective of eat this
eat don't eat that it's also kind of
holistically looking at
you ate the pizza and then you sat on
the couch versus if you eat the pizza
and go for a walk
and so would it be fair to say that uh
the only way to get truly holistic
um kind of measurement of this stuff is
to actually understand what's going on
inside the body combined with what's
going on outside like it almost feels
like if you're just measuring
the external output or you were just
measuring the internal
um kind of uh consumption both of those
things don't tell the whole story so you
kind of need to understand both in order
to really give people
uh kind of a true recommendation of
here's the best thing you can do to be
as healthy as possible
yeah yeah i i definitely think that um
it's both so
the the situation is that people have
for a very long time been scarcity
constrained right for for most of human
evolution we've had um
essentially to be on the constant
lookout for food we
never knew where our next meal was
coming from we were in a constantly
fasted state
between meals and uh we now have a
situation where we
we have an abundance and not only in
abundance but we almost have this
ability
with our our processed food supply to
short-circuit
uh the human metabolism we can in in a
single meal we can get more
fast-acting carbohydrates in in than
uh you know than a prehistoric human
would have had
it would have come across an entire
lifetime and that's not not a joke you
know so
um we now have this situation where
because we didn't
i don't think we evolved uh sensory
feedback
for the quality of what we're eating
because every calorie was positive it
was going to keep you from dying
we don't have the system to give us the
feedback that we need so when we eat
those potato chips
or we we eat that candy you know we
are relying on very very abstract
feedback mechanisms and some sometimes
and for most of us i think it's we wait
for potentially months or years until
the bathroom scale starts to change or
until we get a scary diagnosis at the
doctor
before we start to think about what am i
putting into my body
and so it's necessary in this day and
age specifically when we're
increasingly moving to you know
internet-based productivity
we're becoming as a result more
sedentary
and our processed food supply is
continuing to get more energy dense
it is truly possible to poison ourselves
with abundance and so we have to build
new feedback mechanisms to to give us
that that you know
give us that sensory response that we
otherwise wouldn't have
so uh you know so there's that problem
which is that we you know we
we genuinely do need this as a function
of where we are
in in our evolution and then uh
secondarily
there's no sort of one size fits all and
this is where it really gets complex you
know there are some high level things
i'm comfortable saying like candy is
not a good idea you know you're just
it's just sugar and we
that is such an energy dense system or a
situation that
our systems can't handle it and this is
coming from someone who is a confessed
recovering candy-a-holic and i'll go
into those threes in a minute but
um but beyond that it gets more nuanced
so to the question of like
a cookie versus a banana you know which
which is healthier
most people i think would answer pretty
easily that the banana's healthier
well in 2015 there was a the largest
study on non-diabetics with continuous
glucose monitors was done
and this was at the weizmann institute
in israel they put 800 subjects
through a week of continuous glucose
monitoring and made them
eat these standardized foods at the end
of the trial they were able to show
that two people could eat the exact same
two foods in this case it was that
banana and a cookie made with wheat
and they could have equal and opposite
blood sugar responses to those two foods
and so one person flat on the banana big
spike for the cookie another person
the exact opposite what that indicates
is that they're also experiencing
opposite hormonal responses so that
insulin release that
drives fat gain or ultimately is
associated with insulin resistance and
type 2 diabetes
could be opposite for these two people
so it is truly the case i think that
not only do we have the concern about
what we're presented with every day in
terms
of options but we have to go another
layer deeper if we really want to be
optimal in the sense that we we should
also understand specifically how we
our our own individual genotype or
phenotype
responds to that specific food you know
our own chemical makeup
and i think much of this is context so i
actually believe that only a small
fraction is genetics
driving those individual responses and
the rest is
something like stress body composition
uh so so basically
how much fat you have on your body how
much muscle you have on your body how
well slept you are
how much cortisol and insulin are
circulating in your bloodstream at any
time
that's all what dictates how your body
is going to respond to a specific meal
and so that's why the levels the levels
system
is focusing on bringing in much more
than just nutrition it's nutrition in
combination with your activity level
with your sleep quality ultimately with
your with your stress through additional
analyte tracking
and um this way we can help you identify
which of the levers you should pull on
hardest you know if it's a situation
where
you're experiencing severe metabolic you
know dysfunction as a
as a result of non-caloric decisions
so you're in very stressful meetings all
day and you're sleeping very poorly and
your blood sugar is chronically elevated
because you're in a state of
essentially an enhanced fight-or-flight
mode
we can highlight that as opposed to
someone who's eating candy all day you
know that's a that's a little bit of an
easier connection to make
yeah it's fascinating to me that uh
you're able to get
such a great understanding of the
holistic picture
uh you mentioned earlier metabolic
health and i want to make sure that
people really understand this i think
this is kind of the
crux of everything you're talking about
here what exactly
is metabolic health and then what are
the things that
uh people who have great metabolic
health or really bad metabolic health
kind of experience yeah so this goes
back to
the metabolic fitness conversation and
so metabolic health
the best way to describe it is when the
body is able to produce energy
effectively without harmful byproducts
such that you can perform to the maximum
extent that you need to
and can age gracefully i think that's a
good way to describe metabolic health
it's a complex subject there's a lot
that you could dig into there
but you know what's important is that
many people assume that metabolic health
is something binary
so i'm either very metabolically healthy
or you know oftentimes people say i have
a fast metabolism
or i have a slow metabolism and i'm
metabolically unhealthy
the reality is that and this has been
studied and
international essentially conventions of
diabetes experts
have come out and said there is no such
thing as thresholds right everyone
exists on this spectrum of metabolic
health and
we've drawn these lines in the sand and
said this is this is
diabetes this is very metabolically
unhealthy and this is slightly less
metabolically unhealthy but still bad
and that's pre-diabetes and the rest of
us are all in this other end
you know bucket of the spectrum so what
we're reframing it as
is metabolic fitness it's your fitness
level how well is your body producing
energy
how well is it responding to the
specific lifestyle choices you're making
every day the nutrition exercise sleep
and stress
levers your pulling every single day
combine into a metabolic
profile and so you know we really want
to reframe the conversation
and get people to stop thinking about
this as something that's out of their
hands or
like a switch is flipped and and start
getting us to think in
in terms of focus effort and repetition
if i know what is causing a positive and
or negative response in my body
i can modify those behaviors not just by
removing it you know if i if i love
cheesecake
i don't necessarily have to remove that
if i just add a stroll afterwards
or uh or if i just make sure that i
sleep well that night you know get get a
full eight hours and
that can help me maintain insulin
sensitivity which helps me process
those indulgences um and so connecting
all of these dots for people into a
holistic picture of like
okay all of that abstract advice of eat
healthy
work out more i can now understand
contextually what that means you know
working out more allows me to use the
glucose i'm putting into my body
immediately and and eating better means
avoiding these massive hormonal kicks to
my system which ultimately can break it
down
got it the other part of this that to me
is uh is really fascinating is there's
some
i don't know taboo uh things you can put
in your body
that everyone seems to be uh really
really religious about
so i'm gonna throw a couple of them out
there and you kind of just
throw me back whatever comes to mind
when i say them
uh the first one is alcohol what what's
kind of the thought process there and
what have you guys seen from a trend
perspective
yeah this is i think there's a ton more
studying that should be done
in terms of alcohol and its effect on
metabolism but what we know is that
it's counterintuitive so for most people
the assumption is oh alcohol is all
carbohydrates so if i
eat this while i'm wearing a glucose
sensor my blood sugar is going to
skyrocket
the reality is that alcohol actually
hijacks your liver
it basically tells your liver well your
liver treats it as an emergency
situation
and wants to convert the ethanol in in
the drink
into fat um and that's essentially how
you can metabolize ethanol
so it turns it into triglycerides which
are then stored
on in body fat in order to do that it it
seems to shut down the production of new
blood sugar so what you end up with is a
situation where
on a glucose monitor you have a drink or
two and this various person a person but
there will typically be either no
response or
an actual decrease in in blood sugar and
what's happening behind the scenes
is both the alcohol and anything you're
eating at that time
are being biased towards fat production
and fat storage which is probably not
a great alternative to glucose
production but it is a really
interesting effect and
um you know i think generally for me the
biggest concern with alcohol is just
it destroys my sleep it almost seems
like it doesn't matter when i have it
during the day
my heart rate's elevated my body
temperature is elevated and my sleep is
worse so i tend to think of it as
a stressor that i use sparingly and
typically earlier in the day what about
what i'll label as like the keto diet so
basically i'm going to eat no carbs i'm
only going to eat meat
and i'm basically going to be as you
know strict as possible
um with a fanatical focus on just meat
consumption
yeah well i i think that there are many
ways
to put together a diet that avoids the
sort of energy toxicity that we touched
on you know where you have
a ton of sugar and really a ton of fat
either of those can cause essentially
toxicity in the metabolic system
so what i think is important is that you
you don't do what i just mentioned don't
eat a very the standard american diet
which is high carbohydrate and very high
fat including uh poor sources of fat
i think the ketogenic diet it's very
hard to maintain in my experience
i personally am not keto and i instead
strive for
kind of a high protein moderate fat low
carb diet
and uh ultimately that's just that's
just my decision you know my co-founder
casey is she's a plant-based vegan so
she only eats plants she doesn't need
any meat
and she has you know between the two of
us we have totally different
macronutrient profiles she eats a lot
more carbohydrates than i do
but she actually has better blood sugar
control than me and so it that's another
counterintuitive piece where
she's using a lot of this really nuanced
knowledge about how her body metabolizes
specific
foods and in what order so like fiber
fat content along with those
carbohydrates
can modify the way her blood sugar
responds so she's been able to build a
really
high quality plant-based diet i think
i've been able to build a really high
quality more animal-based diet
and at the end of the day there are also
people who are
maintaining exceptional glucose and
probably improving
their risks of of certain chronic
lifestyle concerns
with a ketogenic diet and so what i
think it all comes comes together as is
wherever you are whatever you're able to
pull off whatever your dietary
philosophies are
they should be grounded in some
objective data so that you can confirm
that this is actually doing what you
think it does um and there have been
plenty of people who have come in having
kind of predetermined
assumptions about a specific either a
specific food or a philosophy or dietary
approach
that have you know been blown up in the
face of better data
absolutely uh intermittent fasting seems
like
another one of these themes or trends
that people are grabbing on to
how have you guys seen that uh impact
some of this
so um intermittent fasting with a
glucose monitor is pretty cool because
you can see the effects of your body
doing its thing
essentially when you cut out
carbohydrates or really when you cut out
all calories
um most people think that they're going
to kind of plummet their blood sugar's
going to drop and they're going to have
this fatigue issue and they're going to
probably pass out or something
and the first time that you do an
extended fast and you see that actually
all of this like these spikes and drops
and all of the
hormonal fluctuations associated with
that completely disappear
and your body goes into this very
elegant mode where
it is taking what you have on on
yourself your
your sort of existing body fat and it's
converting it into
the appropriate amount of blood sugar to
keep your brain functioning
and so you'll typically see like a nice
slow decrease and then a very flat
blood sugar line and most people feel
really good and when you see that data
when you see that feedback loop and
realize
that you can actually maintain this for
days without any calories and you're not
going to pass out
most people you know of course there's
some some of us who have a condition
that prevents that but
um the reality is most of us have um
you know the average person has about 80
000 calories of
body fat stored on them and they only
have about 2000 calories of stored
sugar which is called glycogen so you
can you can easily burn through
that 2000 calories of glycogen in a
single 90 minute workout
but you can go multiple days on the body
fat stores so
training your body to using you know i
think
mechanisms like intermittent fasting to
tap into that body fat and become
more acclimated to using it i think is a
really great approach
and i do a lot of it myself it helps to
kind of release you from from the grasp
of food
scheduling as well you know it's nice to
be able to do one meal instead of three
sometimes
absolutely uh the other thing that i
find fascinating about all of this
is uh multivitamins and just what i'll
kind of label as
uh not food yet trying to get some sort
of nutrient
impact how do you guys see that playing
out are there any trends or takeaways
i think there are some supplements that
probably make sense um
if you if you certainly if you know
you're going to be um
i think it compromised on them i think
vitamin d is a really good one
vitamin d is super important and
especially as we like in winter months
or
are indoors i think vitamin d
supplementation makes a ton of sense
magnesium
is another uh i think really important
supplement that i take commonly
um especially when fasting and um
i tend to i eat a lot of avocados and i
i do add bananas in here and there for
potassium those are the ones that i've
noticed the symptoms or side effects
associated with too little of that you
know specific
vitamin or supplement beyond that i i
tend to be skeptical
um if there there isn't good research
connecting
a uh you know a specific effect of
of too little then i would argue that
you're probably just
urinating most of it out because many of
these supplements tend to have like 10
000 times your
your necessary daily value and um
you know this goes to the the if some is
good is more better
type concept and i think generally no um
there's a sweet spot for almost
everything and and just taking a
multivitamin
probably isn't doing much that you
couldn't get from a better diet
um so let's talk a little bit about the
bio wearables so we talked a lot about
kind of what you're measuring and how
that can be impacted but the actual
device itself and kind of this
growing class of things i put on my body
that measure something going
on inside of my body how do you see that
evolving over time and is that something
that levels will say look you know we've
got one product we want to eventually
expand into an entire product suite
or is it just staying you know really
really focused on that glucose
monitoring
yeah i think we're just cracking the
shell on bio wearables right now um
i consider levels to be kind of like a
bow wave into
an entirely new market that has
previously been undiscovered of
um you know the the metabolically aware
or the nutrition aware or the uh
honestly the health seeker who
wants to continually know that they're
making positive compounding returns
on their lifestyle investments right
we're each we're making decisions all
day every day whether it's
going to the gym taking time away from
family to do that or eating food that
may not taste
as good as that delicious donut but
we're doing it because we want to
improve our health
and um and so we're opening up an
opportunity to get
those micro optimization receipts like
your your
what you're doing is working or not
working and here's how to do it better
and to continually feel like you are
moving in a positive direction
glucose is one piece of this it's a
really important
you know i mentioned some some stats in
the beginning it's a really important
problem
in society today glucose dysfunction and
um all of the side effects associated
with it
are ravaging over 120 million people
each year are dealing with some sort of
metabolic dysfunction that is
preventable
so we're going to stay focused there and
continue to expand access to that
technology and
uh improve the actionability but but
it's one of many you know and so we're
going to continue to
push innovation and look to work with
innovative companies who are developing
the next
generation of sensors that are going to
go a little bit deeper in the in the
direction of bio-wearables and i think
this will probably be
real-time sensing of hormones like
cortisol and insulin
which are associated with your stress
and how your body is allocating
you know fat storage um and probably
deeper into
kind of lipids and triglycerides so
ultimately i think you'll be able to get
a really good
immediate view on your your full
metabolic health not just your glucose
regulation
and it'll probably be i would imagine in
a consolidated form
so you'll wear one thing on your body
and it will do everything that your
current wearable does
plus it's measuring molecules below the
skin which i think is the ultimate
it's the holy grail of of longevity
using these um
you know these you know closed loop
feedback sort of fashion
for sure you've mentioned a couple of
times uh real time um
especially focus on like the real-time
data collection or uh or
presentation uh is that something that
previously just
wasn't available and now there's the
technology and kind of the platforms to
do it in real time
um is there some other reason why that's
kind of the future or is it just
literally if you have more data and
you're able to track it in real time
then you can be more effective in
the recommendations and ultimately the
behavior change
yeah i mean we have a theory of behavior
change that it is closed loops
that make the difference so most people
do not want to be unhealthy
and ultimately it's by prolonging the
the length of time between an action and
the negative reaction to that action by
prolonging that
you allow the sort of behavior change
piece
to dissipate right we our memory just
sort of dissolves and we we
lose the immediate reinforcement that
happens whereas if you do something you
touch a hot stove and immediately
feel pain you don't touch hot stoves
anymore if you were to
eat something and immediately feel pain
you wouldn't eat that thing anymore and
as we mentioned there is no sensory
system for that so
by replacing in as close to the same
amount of time as possible
that sensory feedback with a visual
or a data-driven feed piece of feedback
we can help to supplement people's
senses of positive and negative when it
comes to these things like nutrition
and so i i do think that the timeliness
of a piece of feedback is crucial
to its to the to behavior change so
we're all about
minimizing feedback loops we we don't
really
um focus on you know blood tests where
you do it once and you get
you know results two weeks later or
something like that they're non-specific
it's much more temporal so it's you eat
lunch and you see how you respond to
that minutes later
and then you eat dinner later another
lesson on dinner
and then you can do that over and over
again and you have hundreds of
permutations of exploration in a 28-day
period
and each of those was an opportunity for
immediate lesson learning
that's where i think all of the behavior
change value is and that's what our team
you know believes and has
we've written about in our theory of
behavior change is that
by taking microelectronic technology
using it you know we've unlocked a huge
amount of opportunity with
with this you know essentially the the
minimization of
um you know size scale and cost of of
electronics we can now
build these these closed feedback loops
for a huge number of data vectors and
i think completely change the trajectory
of of health not to mention many other
things uh you know as we're seeing in
finance and elsewhere
is it going to be a world where
literally we all have a bunch of sensors
on and we're walking around there's like
a live dashboard
and uh we almost get to like a
predictive state where it says hey
you're about to eat
x don't eat x or uh hey you're about to
lay down on the couch don't do that
go for a walk like you know how kind of
real time slash predictive does this get
um and then also how pervasive do these
technologies come into our life
uh and is that something that we
necessarily want or i don't know you
guys have built this so
you tell me kind of how you guys are
thinking about some of the uh
you know making it available is one
thing uh wanting the whole world to use
something
um it has kind of a whole bunch of other
connotations to it
yeah i mean i think that in in the long
run you know i would like to
see us reverse the trends of metabolic
dysfunction you know that 88
were unhealthy i'd like to see that be
the healthy set and you know only 12
percent of us are dealing with
preventable chronic lifestyle related
illnesses
if we could see that i mean i think the
productivity we'd see and the benefits
to society would be
hard to hard to even imagine uh the
direct costs of diabetes are expected to
be over 600 billion in 2030
in the us alone and so um you know the
secondary effects
uh i are as i mentioned you know it's
really hard to trace them
so i think it's important that we ramp
up our focus
on uh metabolic health in in the nearer
term
but i don't think it's going to be an
invasive thing you know i i think this
technology is going to continue to
to develop and refine and
it's going to be much more much more
similar to
a financial data sort of feedback model
where
you um you get feedback you see your
withdrawals and deposits you see the
compounding
rate and direction of return on your you
know quote-unquote investments so what
you're doing each day you see the
connection to
your long-term plan you know that
retirement trajectory that you're that
you're on
you get expert advice if you need it you
know if you want to do something
specific
or if you just generally want someone to
coach you along the way you can have
that
directly and it's driven by data it's
not abstract and guesswork
and so ultimately i think with metabolic
health and really health generally
by having that same data-driven you know
very large data set per individual type
of relationship
um you know to ourselves we can we can
build a similar model where
you know you're you're slowly but surely
working towards that that future where
you are
not only you know financially retired
but also know you're going to be healthy
enough to enjoy it type of thing and
and so it will be kind of a background
layer available
confidence you you'll be able to build
confidence in what you're doing
and um i do think it will be predictive
in the sense that
uh you know the devices will be able to
tell you hey look
you didn't sleep at all on that on that
red-eye flight and you should avoid
these foods
those don't work for you when you're
under this kind of stress from poor
sleep
recommend this menu instead um very
simple
low cognitive overhead it's not invasive
but it just takes away that guesswork
and you know
okay yeah i'm compromised on sleep this
is going to help me be healthier and
you can connect that right with your
goals yeah i i love that and i think
that you're probably more right than
than wrong there uh before i wrap up i
was asking everyone the same three
questions
uh the first one is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
yeah this one i've had to ponder a
little bit i'm gonna say
uh the this book was extremely important
to me it's only i've only recently read
it so
um you know i'm putting it in on a high
pedestal but it is amazing and it's
extreme ownership by
jocko willink uh i think that the way he
reframes
so many of life's problems into a very
simple binary where
uh it is your responsibility like that's
that's just all it comes down to is like
if you just
take away all the the mental
argumentation about whose responsibility
it is and
and accept that it is your
responsibility to improve
um every single day everything that you
do everything you're involved in
um it's a position of power actually
it's an empowerment book and that's what
i loved about it was it was taking
something that
sounds on the outside like a burden and
turns it into
a real mechanism for empowerment which i
love
yeah i i think that uh that book is even
though everyone knows about it for those
that haven't read it uh they feel like
there's no way it could live up to the
hype but uh but definitely
uh does at least in my opinion it sounds
like you as well um
when it comes to sleep uh our friends at
eight sleep
uh they've sponsored this question and
as uh i've talked about the podcast
before they basically have this
bed uh that cools and helps you get
deeper sleep
uh and just a much more kind of
refreshing sleep i sleep on one every
night and uh and
absolutely love it what's your sleep
schedule do you do anything before sleep
do you do anything specific
uh during sleep um or any kind of things
that have changed over the years
yeah i uh i love the eight sleep folks i
have my eight sleep pod pro that i have
not yet unboxed but i am absolutely
ecstatic that i
finally have it um i feel like you're
you're measuring what goes in people's
body they're measuring what happens when
you go to sleep
you guys should be friends we are
friends yeah they're great
great friends of ours and supporters so
i'm glad to hear that they've
they sponsored this question i i'm a a
warm sleeper like i
always wake up in the middle of the
night just uncomfortably warm
and so that thermo regulation that they
incorporate i think is going to be a
total
game changer for me i'm really excited
to put it to the test and
you know generally i i've over the time
that i've been using
metabolic tracking glucose tracking
specifically to understand how well my
body's performing
i've totally changed my perspective on
sleep you know i used to be a sleep when
you're dead type person
like that's that's weakness and just
recognize
very quickly how bad my my situation was
to give some context i was actually
borderline pre-diabetic or fully
pre-diabetic when i started
this company levels despite being a
crossfit trainer and
always caring about physical fitness and
so everything that was going wrong
was not my degree of body fat or my
exercise it was that i was eating foods
that were putting me into a bad place
and sleeping poorly and being highly
stressed
so my current approach now i track sleep
with whoop i also have my garmin 245
that
that do sleep tracking and between the
two of them they've forced me to
recognize that
i can't drink alcohol close to bed uh
really even in the afternoon
i can't eat meals you know within about
two hours of going to sleep and i have
to get
at least seven hours i i do pretty well
after seven hours but
um ideally eight hours every night and
um light is another real big one i just
i just
cannot get the same recovery scores when
i have um
you know light streaming in so if you uh
you don't drink in the afternoon or at
night does that mean that you're
waking up and pounding a couple of shots
well i got to tell you man some of these
some of these other european cultures i
think have it figured out
um no but seriously it is interesting to
look at places like italy
um where oftentimes you'll have a glass
of wine like sort of in the afternoon
and a big meal in the afternoon
and then you know get up and walk and
and relax and then
go to sleep relatively early and i think
that gives the the alcohol some time to
metabolize out of the system
might be there might be something to it
yeah
i love it makes a lot of sense uh last
question
you'll get to ask me one to finish up is
uh aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer i'm a believer
and one of my sort of
mental problems to wrestle with is the
fermi paradox
about you know with the vastness of the
universe
why are there not aliens absolutely
everywhere one of my favorite books on
this i was this was going to be like the
other book that i was going to say
in your first question is the three-body
problem
this is written by i always screw his
name up possession lu i think
and totally amazing kind of it has a
really beautiful
explanation for why aliens may not be
revealing themselves and so
um i just think like probability wise
very unlikely that we're alone and i
want to figure out why
we haven't seen anyone yet before you
ask me
the last question uh i gotta ask and i
don't know why i didn't think about this
earlier
uh any idea if elon believes there's
aliens
or like what's spacex's like internal
like general view on this
yeah um so generally i think people look
at the statistical probability and
and think yeah we're very likely not
alone in the universe but
given the fact that we have as far as we
can tell a very hard limit on the fast
like how fast we can travel which is the
speed of light and
the size of the universe doesn't
actually matter because there's only so
far that
we could ever make it in you know a
million lifetimes and so
at a certain point it's like well the
universe is actually not as big as it
really is because we just could never
interact with anything
that far away um so i think that kind of
cuts into it it's like well maybe maybe
aliens are just on the opposite side of
the universe and will never come across
them and so elon's perspective is
we don't know that there are aliens all
we know is that we are the only
conscious life forums
and consciousness has to be preserved
and so that's kind of the underlying
philosophy of wanting to get to mars is
to preserve like
as far as we know until we come across
intelligent beings
besides ourselves we kind of have a
responsibility not to extinguish
our own existence so it's a pretty
compelling
mission there for sure what question you
got for me to uh to finish up
is one i've been grappling a lot with
i'm looking forward to hearing your
thoughts
i gotta ask has social media been good
or bad for society on balance
oh i think huge huge net positive uh
overall um i you know look i'm biased i
worked at facebook for
uh for two years um and i think that
until i worked there i didn't really
understand kind of the net positive
aspect of it i just thought i was like
agnostic i didn't really have an opinion
but when you start to understand the
benefits of everything from like a high
level just hey you connect billions of
people together and now they can
communicate you know do commerce
coordinate
and all that kind of stuff there's a lot
of benefit to that
two is you start to understand um
the human element of it like you know
hey you and i
we were in first grade together i moved
to a different country and then i find
you 30 years later and like we reconnect
there's some of that type of just
objectively positive impact on the world
that happens
um and then the last thing is uh there's
just this argument that like
the platforms and all they actually even
throw in like the messaging applications
and social media applications
like they're one of the last stands
against uh kind of overreaching
governments
like if the people can't communicate uh
via
encrypted you know manner or can't
create a facebook group or go to an
event or whatever like
that's probably not a good thing um but
with all of that said like there's
definitely downsides to it right
and i kind of just think uh the folks
who make the argument like
social media isn't good or bad the
impact can be good or bad but really the
impact is merely like a mirror of who we
are as a society
so like you know if we're all getting
worked up about something like it's
worse on social media right if we're all
really happy about something it's worse
on social media
um and so i think that it's more of like
an amplification
type thing and so if you think of it
through that perspective
then the question becomes like are we
good people are bad
and like you know frankly yeah like
frankly you know there's an argument
depending on what group uh what
geographic location at what time
like for good or bad you know people
right and kind of like good or bad
actions so
i think it's obviously super complex um
and there's frankly no
right answer but the positive impact i
saw i think drastically outweighs the
negative impact
but anyone who's making like a perfectly
blind argument just like oh
everything is great on the internet and
like the internet's amazing and so are
social media and all the stuff and
there's no negative impact like
i think like you could pretty much now
assume that like that argument doesn't
you know really kind of stand the stand
the test of time
yeah i mean we're figuring it out still
it's the early stages it's it's
interesting to be
to have seen like the whole chronology
you know it's gonna be amazing to see
what happens 20 years from now
i uh i continue to joke that uh
you know the saying uh the revolution
will be uh televised
it's like the revolution will be tweeted
right to some degree
like like absolutely absolutely history
you know historians will go back and
they'll just look at facebook posts and
tweets and stuff like that too
so listen man i really really appreciate
you taking the time to do this josh uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh or find more about
levels
yeah so i'm on twitter at joshua's
forest with two r's
and i'm on instagram josh.f.clementi
and then levels i highly recommend
everyone check out the website
levelshealth.com
and the blog in particular which breaks
down a lot of this
sort of abstract you know metabolic
stuff into understandable approachable
terminology that you can
kind of bring home every day and we're
on instagram and twitter at levels
i uh i i found the blog to be amazingly
helpful so i definitely
uh suggest other people go check it out
as well um and hopefully we will
we'll send some people over to uh to you
guys and uh and also find you on twitter
so thanks so much for doing this man
i'll do it again in the future
absolutely thanks for having me on pom